are you kidding me
i don't think i've ever seen the macbook
be more embarrassed in my life has
microsoft finally made an m1 macbook pro
killer well they seem to think so and
they might be right so today we're gonna
compare the brand new surface laptop
studio to apple's m1 macbook pro in
every single category including the
brand new screen microphones speakers
and webcam that they have cpu and
graphics performance real world things
like photo and video editing displays
battery life and more now microsoft has
made some major claims and i'm so
excited for this comparison but before
we test those out let's talk about the
external differences as far as design
you guys can see that the surface laptop
studio is larger than the macbook pro it
is also heavier and noticeably more
chunky it comes in at 3.8 pounds
compared to three pounds and you guys
could see just how much longer and how
much taller it is and as far as
thickness well
this surface laptop studio is a thick
boy you guys can see the difference
right there and there's a good reason
for that of course we have the new
screen size and that hinge but the other
reason is the cooling microsoft is
saying this is some amazing cooling in
this machine you can see these vents on
the full side there if i spin around to
the other side we have the whole side
there as well and we are going to test
out how good that cooling system works
now on the side right here you guys see
microsoft's charger and surface
connector and then the headphone jack
and then on the other side just like the
macbook pro we have two thunderbolt
ports microsoft's saying this is usb4
slash thunderbolt 4. the macbook also
has this as well now the star of the
show is that new hinge and i have to say
i am very impressed not only can we use
this as a laptop but then it splits off
like this kind of like the magic
keyboard for the ipads but you can
completely flatten it down and use it
like this in the surface setup so if you
have this the new surface pen too
you can draw this way the screen works
great for that and then at the bottom
here you can magnetically attach it and
charge the pen as well so hides right
there under that slot now this kind of
design where it's kind of two-tiered
that helps hide how thick and how chunky
this machine is but i guess it's a lot
better than just having it be all flat
and you have the extra capability for
the surface pen now unfortunately there
is no tension so you can't just adjust
the angle and leave it up in the air
like this but there are some magnets
built in so it will magnetize to uh the
laptop the base right there and then you
can literally have it set up like this
for being able to watch movies or when i
do anything online use the touch screen
and then still have access to the
trackpad so that part of it is very nice
and then with that you can actually
magnetize it to the backside and then
literally just set it up like this and
not have that trackpad in the way so
this machine is very versatile
and if apple would put a touch screen on
their macbooks this is what i would want
of course you have the thickness but
having that capability is nice and with
our macbook all we get to do is just use
it like a regular screen with a regular
laptop taking a look at the insides now
if we didn't have a change of color in
the touch bar with the m1 macbook pro
these would look so similar in design
that's not a bad thing now of course you
guys could see the difference in
displays i'm going to touch on that in
just a bit there's a lot of interesting
differences uh same thing with the
webcams but first let's talk about the
keyboards and track pads the keyboard on
the laptop studio is really nice it
feels great to type on you have just
enough feedback you have a little bit of
that clickiness that feels more like a
mechanical keyboard than a cheap one it
is very good and as far as the m1
macbook pro the new magic keyboard also
very good i would say it's a tie between
them now the other interesting thing is
the track pads of course with the max we
have the force touch track pad that's
magnetic it actually clicks back at you
with a completely even feel and this
year microsoft is basically doing the
same thing it uses magnets it gives you
tactile feedback and has an even feel
all around it is glass it's almost like
a copy but i will say this is one area
that i'm glad they copied apple in
because this is way better than any
other windows trackpad i have ever used
and now let's compare the speakers
microsoft surface line has been really
good in the past couple of years and
they are saying that this has new quad
omnisonic speakers with dolby atmos i'm
not even sure what that is but let's go
ahead and compare them and see how these
stack up
so
are you kidding me
i don't think i've ever seen the macbook
be more embarrassed in my life
uh we listened to a couple other little
tracks i have this open right here our
classic this is a huge difference i
think that the surface laptop studio is
louder than even the 16-inch macbook pro
with six speakers i don't know about the
sound quality we'll have to test that
but this is a huge difference not only
is it much louder has better bass the
vocals are nice and smooth the mids are
loud
wow usually it's the macbook
embarrassing other windows laptops
obviously this thing is larger right
they have room for better speakers but
most windows manufacturers don't make
use of that space you'll open it up
it'll be all this empty space in there
wow microsoft props to you guys these
speakers are mind-blowing they're loud
and they sound great whatever omni sonic
whatever that is keep doing that and
more people please do that because these
sound phenomenal so right away we know
who the winner is there now let's move
on to the webcam and the microphones
microsoft is saying that this has ai
power in the webcam we have dual
front-facing microphones right there
let's switch over that and see how these
compare this is the microphone and
webcam quality from apple's m1 macbook
pro using the same 720p camera as before
but with the new processing from the m1
and this is the microphone and webcam
quality from the surface laptop studio
with its 1080p camera and dual
front-facing microphone so you guys go
ahead and let me know down in the
comment section below which one looks
better and which one sounds better and
now let's compare the displays starting
out with authentication our macbook pro
has touch id so you simply put your
finger on the button and you get logged
in whereas the surface laptop studio has
windows hello so as soon as you open up
bam it just logs you right in this is
something we've wanted in max for a long
time we want face id built in because it
is a lot more convenient as you can tell
the studio has a noticeably larger
display coming in at 14.4 inches
compared to 13.3 and it's a three by two
display instead of 16x10 what's
interesting is as far as the vertical
resolution they both come they both come
in at 1 600 pixels and on the horizontal
we have 2400 versus 2560s so a little
bit less pixels on microsoft's larger
display but both of them look really
nice and sharp i went ahead and adjusted
that top camera so we can compare the
brightness and what's interesting is
that microsoft's display is actually
slightly brighter than apple's 500 nit
display now they didn't even advertise
the brightness but they are doing a
great job taking a closer look at the
displays i have this video opened up
right here now for some reason the
surface laptop studio would not let me
play hdr video no matter what settings i
changed which browser browser i use this
is a non-hdr 4k video and it is
interesting the differences that i
noticed first off the brightness now
looks brighter on the mac pro though
brights pop a little bit more and look
at that difference in contrast now this
display here the microsoft does have
good contrast but the reflectivity is
off the charts just like the previous
surface laptops their screens are very
reflective and you just see the
difference in contrast there the macbook
has a lot deeper blacks
the brightness pops more detail looks
about similar because the pixel density
is about the same and then the
highlights pop more as well and keep in
mind both these videos are not hdr so
there's no bias towards the macbook pro
i went ahead and paused this scene right
here so you guys can see the difference
now the macbook pro displays up to p3
wide colors whereas the surface laptop
studio is limited to srgb so it can't
produce as wide of a color spectrum
so as far as reflectivity you guys saw
the lower contrast this is not a deal
breaker if you're working in a darker
environment but if you're in a brighter
room or outside it definitely is going
to get in the way with that said the
surface has another major advantage and
that is the fact that its display is 120
hertz now this is great for gaming it's
also great if you just love having a
super smooth display instead of 60 hertz
on the macbook pro of course like the
new iphones have 120 hertz which is
great but with that if you're going to
be using that pen support for drawing
that makes it a lot more responsive
which is probably why microsoft made
this display 120 hertz and now let's get
into performance i'm going to start out
by testing out the ssds both of these
machines have 256 gigabyte ssds so let's
go ahead and run the speed test all
right wow you guys see the difference
right there for yourselves i'm really
surprised that microsoft's ssd the 256
gig one is that slow as far as write
speed we're looking at 995 compared to
about 2500 and for read 1800 compared to
2300 using the same exact settings with
this cross platform aja ssd test now of
course if you get the larger capacities
that will be quicker but apple has made
their ssds much faster even on the base
models with the m1 systems next let's
compare the cpu and the graphics
performance now the model i have here is
the base model i purchased this one so
that would be fair against the m1
macbook pro and to review what a lot
more people can afford with that said i
do want to test out the one that has
dedicated graphics when the m1x comes
out which will be very soon we're very
excited for you guys see this shirt
right here m1x if you guys want to buy
one of these or maybe a hoodie you guys
want to support our channel we have
links down below and also in the merch
shelf and with that if you want to see
this laptop with that dedicated graphics
and the i7 compared to the m1x macbook
pro click that subscribe button you guys
can also help us reach our goal of 1
million subscribers with that said let's
go ahead and run the cpu benchmark now
this is a new 11 300h chip in the
surface laptop studio it's a new updated
tiger lake chip that intel has released
um and has really good clock speeds 3.1
base up to 4.4 gigahertz for the boost
clock compared to just a flat 3.2 with
apple's m1 macbook pro all right wow
actually that is better than i expected
this score right here is very close to
the i7 model
at least the scores that i looked up on
geekbench's website but they still don't
compare with the m1 chip of course this
is an eight core processor we have four
performance cores like the one in the
surface laptop and then the efficiency
cores totaling 7730 multi-core which is
about 43 percent more performance than
the 5400 of the studio and as far as
single core we have a difference about
24
now we will see how this affects us in
the real world and with that this laptop
here has 16 gigs of ram compared to 8
gig for my base model macbook pro so
we'll see if we get a difference there
now i'm going to go ahead and close this
down and do keep in mind both these are
unplugged but doesn't seem like we're
suffering any performance loss with
those scores and i do have a set to
maximum performance and next i'm gonna
go ahead and run the graphics test we're
gonna use metal for the m1 and then we
will go ahead and use vulcan for the
intel iris graphics with this new
processor and wow once again
that is a big difference in performance
there this time it's lower than i
expected we have 11 700 compared to 21
400 so uh the eight graphics course
inside the m1 chip they're pretty much
twice as powerful as this surface so you
might actually wanna have that dedicated
uh graphics card if you can afford uh to
pay for that price tag that they're
asking now of course the m1x is gonna
have a lot more graphics power so that
will be an interesting comparison now
i'm really curious are we losing
performance being on battery power at
least in terms of graphics i went ahead
and plugged in the surface connector
charger and let's go ahead and run that
one more time all right well for the
third time
look at that we're looking at 15
644
compared to previously unplugged
seven hundred seventy eight so you
definitely lose graphics performance if
you unplug it that's a 33 percent
increase in graphics performance when
you plug it in even if both are set to
maximum performance that is a shame and
even with that improved performance the
macbook pro is still about 37
more powerful now on the positive note
one thing that i just realized is that
when i was running both of those test
cpu and gpu i did not hear either one of
these laptops fans spin up both were
completely silent and that is extremely
rare for a windows laptop when that
multi-core kicks in or the graphics
tests kick in you hear the fans so let's
go ahead and pull out our thermal camera
and see what these are running at
temperature wise and then we'll get into
cinebench and see how hot and how loud
they get so far the surface has been
impressive so it looks like the hottest
part of the laptop studio is at 31
degrees celsius right there in the
center and looking at our macbook pro
that's at 29 degrees closer to the touch
bar over there on the left hand side so
the m1 macbook pro is definitely running
cooler but both are silent so let's go
ahead and open up cinebench let's go
ahead and get started i'm running the
multi-core test that's going to run for
10 minutes to test throttling and i have
cpu id opened up right here just so we
can see the wattage and wow that's
running at 45 watts so we are maxing out
that intel chip this is the new one that
the wattage actually goes up from about
35 max to 45 46 right there and as far
as temperatures we're at 87 88 degrees
celsius 91 so now i'm just slightly
starting to hear the fans but we're
pushing it to the limits just like on
the macbook pro but with the mac before
look at that we're only at 454 degrees
celsius so it is staying much cooler and
as soon as i barely heard those fans it
looks like the wattage dropped now to
about 35 34 it's hovering right over
there 36 temperatures went down to 77
which is really good and as far as the
fan noise
very minimal i mean i could barely hear
it over the h facts so maybe microsoft
does have something that is working very
well with this new system i feel the
fans as well right here on the side not
the fans but the heat which is
interesting so it's rid it's like it's
funneling it to the body the macbook is
completely cool let's give it a few more
minutes and at the five minute mark
we'll see what the temperatures are all
right it's been five minutes so far and
look at that we're looking at 39 degrees
celsius at the hottest part but look how
much heat we have
with the palm rest i definitely felt
that at the start and then literally on
the table off the side you guys could
see that it's literally just hitting the
macbook pro with a bunch of heat and the
tops are cool so this is a pretty good
design where it's sucking in air from
the top and then blowing it out there at
the bottom and for the macbook pro our
hottest part is at 38 degrees celsius
pretty much the same
but the machine over here is much cooler
where your hands are other than where
the surface laptop
is just blowing on the macbook pro and
now after seven minutes of running this
thing is just staying extremely
consistent about 80 degrees celsius 77
to 80 kind of bounces and it's sticking
at a full 35 watts so no slowing down
like you get with the dell xps and other
laptops it'll drop down to 15 after a
while and as far as frequency it's
sitting about 3.7 gigahertz on all four
cores compared to 3.2 on the performance
cores of the m1 macbook pro and here in
a couple minutes we'll see our final
results all right the test is almost
done i kept lifting up the macbook so
that's not getting drowned by heat and i
have to say
that this is probably the quietest
windows ultra book and maybe laptop in
general that i've heard running through
cinebench without throttling down the
system it stayed right there at 35 watts
and it is very quiet almost as quiet as
the m1 macbook pro that did spin up here
at the end
that is very impressive so it does seem
like this cooling system is as good as
what they're saying now let's go ahead
and see the final result we're waiting
for this last run to finish we have a
great score of 7735
for the m1 macbook pro and for the
surface laptop studio we have 5
63. that is a difference of 36 and a
half percent in favor of the m1 macbook
pro even though the m1 chip uses 15
watts of power instead of about 35 watts
of power for this intel latest chipset
that recently came out and it actually
peaked at 47 watts so definitely a lot
more performance for the wattage
but i'm still pretty impressed with the
cooling system being able to keep that
chip cool when it's running so much
power to it compared to the m1 macbook
pro and now let's go ahead and close
this down and let's take a look at real
world performance with real applications
all right i have my regular 50 42
megapixel edited raw images opened up
and we already know as far as
performance brush performance and
changing settings moving through photos
both of these are basically identical we
don't see any difference now where we
can see a difference is when it's time
to actually export and turn all these
edited raw images into jpeg files now
remember that the surface laptop studio
does have 16 gigs of ram instead of 8
gigs and lightroom is very ram intensive
so let's go ahead and see how long it
takes to export all the settings are
identical let's hit export and start our
timer so far they look like they're
about the same even though the surface
laptop studio is using about 13 gigs of
ram compared to about seven and the
macbook pro has to use swap memory to
that ssd the cpus are maxed out on both
and i do have the surface laptop studio
plugged in just to make sure we're
looking at the best performance even a
lot of people will use this just
unplugged on the go and bam one of these
machines is done all right and the other
one is done as well
it looks like the macbook pro finished
in two minutes and 25 seconds compared
to two minutes and 49 basically 250 for
the surface laptop studio even though it
has 16 gigs of ram and that does give it
an advantage and that's basically
because of that extra cpu performance
kicking in and helping us out and of
course it has the 8 channel memory
design with the m1 which also does help
so as far as exports it definitely is
faster and it was actually silent here
where as a surface laptop studio
although it was quiet you still did hear
the fans now let's go ahead and close
lightroom and we are going to do a video
editing test this is some black magic
raw footage from the pocket 6k it is
also graded let's go ahead and play it
back and as you guys could see it is
running perfectly smooth on the m1
macbook pro
and it's just a mess on the surface even
though we do have it plugged in to get
the better graphics performance
here looks like we're using about 86 of
the graphics 30 28 30 of the cpu i'm
curious what's happening
on the surface side wow 14 gigs of ram
we're using 93 of the graphics 54 of the
cpu and it is not enough
you guys see that right there it is
being really stuttery compared to being
nice and smooth so it looks like if
you're into video editing
you definitely are gonna have a much
better experience with the macbook even
though for photos yes it's slower to
export editing experience isn't that big
of a difference for video that is big
and now let's go ahead and export this
fairly short i think it's a one minute
project and see how long it takes bam
let's hit render right there i'm using
h.265 just for the faster encoding and
the better quality for the file size and
we look it looks like we have quite a
bit of difference even for a one minute
project
here it is rendering at about 20 frames
per second compared to
9.5 now of course this is black magic
crop but davinci resolve is way faster
than premiere pro on both of these
systems all right it is finally finished
here it looks like the surface laptop
studio took 2 minutes and 38 seconds
compared to 1 minute and 15
so basically twice as fast and of course
if this was a longer project it'd be
more like 10 minutes compared to over 20
and then you guys saw the difference
when we were playing back now of course
both of these for this test they are
actually limited by the graphics
performance so i'm very interested in
doing this test again once we have the
m1x macbook pros coming out that which
are going to come soon and we'll get the
higher end version with the dedicated
graphics for the surface laptop studio
but for this point the m1 is definitely
faster even if you bought the base model
with eight gigs ram for thirteen hundred
dollars maybe less on sale compared to
sixteen hundred dollars for this machine
now as far as battery life if i go down
and take a look
we currently are at 67 i've been having
it plugged in most of the time and even
the few times where it was unplugged it
was draining really fast it was dropping
we're here we're at now 40 percent so
the m1 sips power like i showed you guys
during um the cpu test it runs at 15
watts instead of up to 47 but averaging
35 37 so in terms of real world battery
life we know that the m1 macbook pro is
basically the leader beating out every
windows laptop and even windows laptop
fans admit that now if we're gonna end
up doing a full review for this laptop i
will talk about real world battery life
but in general what most people are
saying that's about 10 hours of battery
life compared to about 15 or maybe more
depending on what you're doing for the
m1 macbook pro
and now what is the final verdict well
as you guys heard i was very impressed
with this surface laptop studio if
you're looking for a windows laptop and
you can afford 1600 bucks this thing is
great it is very quiet even under full
load it doesn't drop cpu cpu performance
if you unplug it just some graphics
performance the display is very bright
it has that hinge that can literally pop
open so it's very versatile and of
course if you're somebody that's going
to use the pen you're going to
magnetically charge it and mount it to
the bottom and draw on the screen you're
doing photo retouching you're doing
drawing you have that 120hz display
this thing is going to smoke the m1
macbook pro you can't do that there's no
touch screen no pen support nothing like
that and if you need a windows laptop
this thing is killing it as far as the
track pad the keyboard as you guys saw
very impressive and the speakers were
amazing as well so in terms of windows
laptops if you're okay with that
performance and the performance of this
matches up and he beats other windows
ultrabooks this thing is a great windows
laptop now if you want a lower price and
you want better performance especially
for things like video editing if you do
photo editing you want the better more
color
capable display the m1 macbook pro is
still a real winner it's going to last a
long time great resale value things like
that but it is now being beaten out by
microsoft in many ways which was a
shocker especially the speaker test
there so you guys let me know your
thoughts which one do you think is a
better laptop did microsoft just
embarrass apple
i want to hear your guys opinions down
below click that circle above to help to
subscribe and help us reach 1 million
subscribers that would be amazing and
check out one of those great videos
right over there this has been max and i
will see you in the next video
[Music]